let's get that Center and then let's get
Knight c3 development d6 with c5 or a 5
if you're gonna feed cattle this Bishop
know the two different pawn breaks to
look forward to c5 and e5 both of which
strike at the d4 pawn bishop out sensing
that this is the direction blacks should
be going in I want to reinforce the d4
pawn see how that just follows logically
right there knowing what it is black
wants to do might help you know what
white should be doing in response f3
know why ago f3 f3 is played when the
knight is threatening to play here
there's no need to do it right now I'm
assuming Knight here but until it's
played I'm not gonna do that
so instead I'm lining up for an eventual
dark square Bishop exchange I'm also
preparing to maybe queenside castle and
what else
what's the scoop okay less than what
well I might have a change of plans here
yeah I have a change of plans here I'm
gonna go with f4 we're seeing right
there with just these last two moves by
me by by the white side reason for
retaining flexibility with moves that
you run with if I had run with f3 and
then saw a 5 and then play to f4 that's
wasting a movie but Queen d2 is
purposeful for this diagonal for
queenside castling and I retained that
flexibility with my F pawn this is
something I am completely welcome to
that Bishop once - you could say a
bishop held in your hand is worth 3
points but in given positions it's may
be worth more or less and if you're
going to run with a king side fianchetto
that bishop is no longer worth 3 it's
worth more than 3 let's just let's just
say it's worth 4 points so really what
just happened there is four points took
three and I recaptured positionally and
maybe I'm up like a 0.1 or something I
know that was a stupid number to be
throwing out I think that it's a good
exchange instead of attaching that type
of value to the pieces it's just it's
very important if you're gonna go with
that fee and cut out setup to hang on to
them because you weaken these squares if
you know as soon as you did g6 you're
weakening those two and now he's no
longer around to watch over them so it's
the black queen who now has to be
watching out for let's say f6 at any
moment I could run with let's say e5 and
then throw my knight here and look to
play to f6 and that could be brutal
it's Castle first and this is what I
have up my sleeve
'if I've followed up with a knight to
one of these two squares really just
eyeing f6
now I
all right let's go here with I guess I
were gonna be seeing b5 so if I'm
playing Bishop here I'm kind of just
walking right into this expansion on the
Queen side I don't really want to allow
that
I think pawn push is the correct move
this Knight is close to being trapped
Irie capture with the pawn because I
want to overtake this f6 square this
Knight cannot move and I think I just
play where if I play here there's a
knight retreat but I'll have something
for that Queen here there's night here
actually it's a little bit annoying
oh wait Queen here hang on what are my
options
Queen here I don't like Knight g4 and
the threat of the fork
Queen here stops Knight their queen here
forces Knight h5 is otherwise Knight
back I just get the Queen Queen here 9
h5 and then maybe I come over to this
Square and then get ready for g4 or
something I don't know or Queen here and
then h6
ah that's the right idea I was focused
on f6 but also h6 is a weak square so
let me do that as Queen f4 and now in
response to Knight h5 I play Queen h6
with the follow up being Knight g5 I'm
glad I took pause in that position right
there I wanted to have a good response
to that knight move so now my queen is
in that week and square that happens
that uh well it's weakened now because
of the dark skirmishes being off pawn
push allows a bishop deployment with
check this night is still pinned
I think this pond needs to move okay now
I could insert a check or even just push
right away I'm gonna insert a check
first kick that king away to h8 and now
this rook needs a babysitter then I just
push and then this is gonna be white
just being up a minor piece now b5 I
could just ignore it
b5 I could just take care or maybe just
play to d5 I have my choice yeah it is
tough I think that the beginning of
black going wrong was the dark square
bishop exchange so I could play here I
could take the night but and try to get
this but after I take the knight the
bishop recaptures and the rooks are
connected I could throw this in first
I play here looking for just paan takes
followed by rook here this Knight can't
move
I get the rook it still can't move it's
no longer pinned to the Queen but it's
just well it's pinned in the sense where
it has a defensive role really just
can't move because it has to watch over
the rope
okay the Queen's come off now I did see
that but now I'm actually getting two
minor pieces one Pig on the seventh
looking for another alright let's just
go here if I take I'm helping that real
come to life let's get rid of pieces
here a knight takes Bishop takes keep
that Bishop right there I'm just looking
for a home for my minor pieces pawn push
weasel the knight around to this square
maybe to protect everything okay
my opponents typing good game good game
let me go back flip the board and see
where there's an improvement right here
here's one thing your knight might want
to play here keep the options open
Knight f6 is probably most common and
best Knight f6 I'm g4 getting ready to
castle consider just Knight f6 and there
might be knight c6 with E 5 as well this
is the better move to be running with at
the very least right here capturing on
this square if you do go with that
capture don't follow up with the bishop
recapture you need to preserve this dark
square bishop he's too important to give
up so early on not a good not a good
thing to run with so keep that in mind
because I think that that is what led to
the problems in the game was just not
having your dark straight Bishop around
I was able to pounce on these f6 squares
or H 6 squares really it turned out to
be the age six squared but there could
have been possibilities for Knight
landing on f6 somewhere along the way
and that could have been a problem so
keep that in mind this guy very valuable
if you're gonna fee and Ketel your
bishop where your king is likely to be
castled you don't want to hang out to
them